>> My name is Bob Edwards.
I'm with the NGP Energy Capital Management,
a large global private
equity fund.
My realization here at Davos on the environment
is that it will be a
long time before a tangible, concrete climate
treaty or even a global
agreement is reached.
In the meantime, it's becoming apparent, and
I think you see it in the
agenda of the conference and certainly in
the buzz of the halls, that
adaptation is going to be critical.
And the debate about food and water is surpassing
the debate now about
wind and solar.
It's a matter now of figuring out what we're
going to do in the next 20
or 30 years as the impact of climate change,
population growth,
urbanization becomes apparent and so that's
the interesting sessions.
How do we get -- how do we feed 9.2 billion
people?
And how do we release the water that's necessary
to irrigate the crops
in order to feed 9.2 billion people?
Thank you.